[Applaudissements]
nous sommes le 12 mars 1977 à fort de
france en martinique
c'est le jour de ma naissance je suis
judicaël g11 doigts et de la peau entre
les doigts
mes pieds sont déformés mes bras sont
plus courts que la normale et mon visage
présente les symptômes du syndrome
rubinstein tv face à ma différence et
pour x raisons mes parents m'abandonne
orphelins à la pouponnière à 24 décembre
1977 d'hercule trice de garde me pris
dans ses bras me regarde et je prononce
mon premier mot maman depuis six jours
me donne une étoile et prie tous les
jours que celle ci me protège toute ma
vie naturellement un devient ma marraine
durant les quatre premières années de ma
vie je suis ballotté entre la résidence
de ma marraine l'orphelinat et les
hôpitaux pour y subir des opérations
afin de rendre fonctionnel mes bras et
mes mains en 1981 j'ai 4 ans je me
souviens jamais main droite un ballon
rouge et en naviguant ce jeu tient la
main de l'assistance sociale qui
m'accompagne à l'aéroport de paris elle
soudain elle se met à ma hauteur
me regarde il m'annonce judicaire je te
présente les nouveaux parents
vient alors philippe rivière et vimont
deuxième abandon désorientée après un
long voyage au sud de la france à ma
nouvelle résidence je découvre une
grande famille composée de quatre filles
deux garçons et métaux parents adoptifs
et je me rends bien compte que je vais
passer ma vie
dans cette famille où les enfants n'ont
pas le droit à la parole alors ce soir
je partage ma vie avec vous mais je ne
la considère pas plus ou moins
douloureuse que la voix je me semble
plutôt qu il était écrit que je devenais
être dans la souffrance vous savourez la
valeur d'une vie qui s'émerveillent qui
respire
et qui s'est construit alors ce soir
je partage ma vie avec vous mais je ne
la considère pas plus ou moins
douloureuse que la vôtre il me semble
plutôt qu il était écrit que je devenais
dans la souffrance pour savourer la
valeur d'une vie une vie qui respire une
vie qui s'émerveillent mais surtout une
vie qui se construit être né sans rien
je ne pouvais que m'élever à l'école
j'apprends à lire je dessine je cours je
ris je pleure comme n'importe quel
enfant
et bizarrement je comprends que je serai
toujours différents jeux des autres en
sixième je me souviens camarades de
classe moquer vulgairement à propos de
mes mains je le tape au visage avec ma
main gauche celle avec la bosse hop tout
droit chez le proviseur
et même si j'ai trouvé injuste
concernant mon égard je me souviens mine
de rien d'une petite phrase qui me suit
depuis toujours on les oignons dans la
violence je suis puni n'est pas
l'entraîneur ghabbour ce camarade de
classe des excuses aux noirs à l'orge et
du pardon comme par exemple gérer mes
études à la recherche d'un stage en
entreprise
certains chefs d'entreprise se veut
ferme la porte au nez en prestance
préfériez préféré payer avant quelques
jours d'avoir menti garer dans son
entreprise
quelle finesse il ya 18 ans pour bien
marquer le coup je reçois enright
stipulant doit souvent que je suis
handicap ou 3e catégories ainsi le siège
est en marche et braquage s'est excusé à
vie contre handicapés alors ce jour là
ma vie bascule et de poser des problèmes
existentiels
je publie chez eux et où je vais
j'ai l'impression d'être à l'abri d'être
mal aimés karoutchi avait signifié
d'être incompétente des sources y
compris des souvenirs je vous suis un
noob et nous mais qui cette fois
l'handicapé s'énerve résultats non des
bonbons
donc je suis handicapé c'est du rhin
décision externe ans par un vrai petit à
petit la chine de godard liberté jérôme
a accompli que le sens de mon histoire
d'être lèvres de battre alors que
personne ne sera plus jamais de moi
perso vous dira comment agir
j'ai le droit au respect et à la dignité
j'ai tout simplement que me tourner
article les étrangers du ver cette
demande qui dit je vais être naissent
libres et égaux
je prends ma liberté
en 1994 j'ai découvre les scans en tant
que je peux rien sur ogier a encore je
viens parce que j'ai dormi bras je n'ai
pas neuf
alors comme nous puissent faire dans
leurs escales à c'est surtout une
question de force et surtout une
question de technique
dès qu'il y ait de compréhension de son
poids face au projet d'entente en moins
de profits
je m'en parle souvent la scam at elle
tourné graphique se sentir dans ses
mouvements
20 saisons dans ses bras et
d'assainissement chaîne les routeurs le
vide le vent soleil la solitude la force
le mental qui m'amène à tous au nez et
toutes ces ascensions sont toujours
différentes et reflète pas l'état de
santé
parfois on se sent bien à cause de
problèmes affectifs et professionnels
alors nous voulons se feront hésitant et
ont reçu des mails ou alors en uefa
s'est affermi son boulot et ses terrains
alors nouveau concevoir sans verser dans
les jardins d'enfants semble maudit s'il
ya un jeu nous donnera la plus grande
satisfaction est cette capacité de
décision nous servent tous les jours
dans ma vie à mon petit les
professionnels les stars c'est pour moi
le premier endroit où je me mettre en
manches courtes et de ne plus gâcher en
été comme en hiver soute langue dimanche
la différence l'espionnage
c'est une façon pour moi vous avez je
pouvais faire une mince nous vous
informions
l'escale d'un permis de me faire penser
aux enduits de gens feront plus escale à
devenir un sport olympique qui olympique
donc je deviens johnny naturel de la
création de la catégorie l'envi auprès
des fédérations internationales et je
prends le risque de vous déplacer sur
des éléments des compétitions d'hommes
ayant le minimum d'argent et cette même
année je fais une démonstration lors des
championnats du monde à chamonix et je
rencontre parfois incidence la plus
grande entreprise de matériel d'escaladé
qui me démarches pour me recruter
je rentre chez moi
gonflé à bloc je me dis philippe a les
meilleurs sponsors désormis encourage et
tu as le temps pourquoi ne pas créer un
événement pour les grimpeurs handicapés
en 2003 je crée le premier événement en
10 grains pour faire grimper les
grimpeurs handicapés et les personnes
valides avec un petit handicap
artificiel je vendais mes pieds attachés
pour qu'ils aient peut-être un petit
aperçu de ce que pourrait être un
accident un handicap
après un accident de voitures de motos
en accidents vasculaires cancers etc et
échanger avec ces sportifs bien fait
comprendre que j'ai mes deux jambes mes
deux bras mes deux yeux mes oreilles
balang et mon cerveau et qu'à la fin
d'autres personnes sont beaucoup plus
handicapé que moi alors je ne me plains
pas et je revois mes problèmes
existentiels dans le bon contexte et je
réalise que je marche
je suis champion d' escalade et je suis
en bonne santé en créant cet événement
j'aide les autres tout en m'aidant moi
même pourquoi sommes-nous envieux de ce
que nous avons déjà encore vivants que
la nature nous a donné alors en 2009
je décide de voyager seules à travers
l'europe dans un camion et je veux
savoir comment le thème du handicap est
abordé dans les autres pays européens
et je veux savoir si la france est en
retard ou pas en matière de ce sujet
mais j'ai aussi soif de connaissance de
ma personnalité et de mon but dans la
vie
alors je grimpe de tous les jours
surtout les rochers européen geie dans
des conférences dans les salles
d'escaladé
on m'invite même dans les ambassades
françaises je dors seul dans les forêts
ou parfois je mets la musique à fond je
danse j'écris jury se vit je vis et lors
de ce tour d'europe je me rends compte
d'un fait qui me fait changé ma vision
de mon handicap et de le rendre beau
pourquoi devrais-je être être parfait
pourquoi devrions-nous être parfait dans
la nature comme d'allah
rien n'est parfait on aime la différence
dans la musique dans la mode dans la
sculpture dans le dessin et cetera
parfois on y dépensant des sommes et non
et
pourquoi avons nous un problème avec les
déficiences physiques et ou déficientes
moral
la nature nous a fait le cadeau de la
vie et nous discriminons les handicapés
les gros les petits les noirs les arabes
un avec un écocide autret des cheveux
comme cela et c est son idée modèle de
perfection nous les humains je m'appelle
philippe ribière et je me tiens devant
vous ce soir
certains me considère encore comme une
personne handicapée et je ne peux rien
changé à cela mon corps et mon costume
unique mon meilleur cadeau une chance
une différence un art et un outil de
travail
je suis champion d' escalade je suis
libre de mes mouvements
j'ai du respect j'ai de l'amitié et j'ai
de l'amour et tout cela je les ai
réalisées grâce et avec vous car vous
m'aidez tous les jours par les petites
choses de la vie
un regard un sourire du blog une parole
intentionnés ont touché à l'épaule mardi
mon cadeau ce soir est de vous dire
merci
[Applaudissements]